in my friend group i'm the only
polyamorous person and i have the least
sex
out of all of my friends willow smith
brought the newest debate
to red tabletop it takes practice to
have those difficult conversations
on wednesday the multi-generation
dynamic got personal once again
this time with willow's revelation that
she's polyamorous
this has been a journey for you miss
willow how did you make this decision
with polyamory i feel like the main
foundation
is the freedom to be able to create a
relationship style that works for you
and not just stepping into monogamy
because that's what everyone around you
says is the right thing to do
the 20 year old singer opened up about
her perspective on polyamory
relationships helping her mom and
gammy understand her desire to have to
have multiple intimate partners at the
same time
so i was like how can i structure the
way that i
approach relationships with that in mind
yeah also
doing research into polyamory the main
reasons why
monogamous relationships or why marriage
why divorces happen is infidelity yeah
yeah let's say you haven't always been
the kind of person that wanted to have
sex all the time
but your partner is right are you gonna
be the person to say you know
just because i don't have these needs
you can't have them either
right throughout the series all three
women have maintained an open mind with
topics about sex
and mom jada pinkett smith's reaction
here was no different
how did you feel when i told you that i
was polyamorous
when you were like hey this is my get
down i was like i totally get it
wanting to set up your life in a way
that you
can have what it is that you want i
think anything goes
as long as the intentions are
clear to everyone most people
are practicing monogamy because they
feel like they have no other choice
right
we all know that most people out here
doing unethical
non-monogamy and while gamey tried to
understand the concept the matriarch
pointed out that many people still
believe in monogamous relationships
there's comfort in that it provides two
almost like a social order yes
to life and setting boundaries and
commitments most i guess i'm not really
clear on
what it offers you could you imagine
being in a group
and loving everyone equally no whether
it be platonic or not
wow well then i don't know what to say
that's because of gam's
ideas around love the conversation also
looked to the future and
willow admitted that for her to walk
down the aisle one day
there would need to be some stipulations
in place first
what are your feelings and ideas around
marriage as you know it today the
history of marriage really irks me
yeah um just the history of marriage as
a whole
and what it has represented over the
years for women in particular
i feel like the only way that i would
get
married is let's say me and my partner
or partners want
to help people and we need to put our
finances together
in order to make that vision happen
that's the only way i could see myself
getting married
these revelatory conversations have
become a trademark of red table talk and
jada told e.t
the secret behind their intense
discussions okay but what is it
about this technique when people come
and sit here what's that magic sauce
that just makes people say yeah i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna spill it
well i guess i don't i think it's not
even so much because that's never
our intention yeah exactly we just
always want to have
just real conversations and so i think
it's um
we're in the conversation with you right
yeah we're we're
we're sharing our stories we're sharing
our experiences
it's a safe space